I think what's important is to
understand what are we demonizing and
what are we scared of so to me privacy
is controllable if somebody's listening
right now and they're like no way Gary
you're so wrong I'm like delete the app
don't have an iPhone like I love the
concept of accountability the amount of
parents that like stop me in the middle
screen saying Tick Tock and I'm like
then delete it off your kid's phone like
the lack of accountability and the lack
of understanding how much control humans
actually have I think it's a cop-out I
think it's because accountability has
come out of favor there's a couple other
things I think a lot about I think about
America Banning alcohol they thought
that that would solve the problem to me
Banning or stopping or being scared is
never the problem it's understanding how
to use everything a car is dangerous if
you don't know how to use it a bottle of
gin is dangerous if you don't know how
to use it sugar is dangerous if you
don't know how to use it I think we need
education and conversation but I think
ultimately it's about accountability